very nervous because the technology is
failing on this pageant 61 days it's
great about my drinking dealing today
everyone and we are doing what is it's
called the blindfold touch what's in my
hand or the what is this challenge okay
what is this challenge I figure this is
a good Monday video because being
blindfolded is very sexy in the world of
things and stuff you don't know how this
works basically I will be blindfolded
myself and Ricky will be placing items
that he has already chosen into my hands
and I will have to guess what it is as
long as it's not your dick gonna be okay
it won't be that right I think we're
doing about five items and we'll see how
many I get and then over on Ricky's
channel we will be reversing and he will
be touching stuff that I put in his
hands and I promise it also won't be my
dick
I hope okay let's get blindfolded and
we're gonna start with my favorite one I
will just cover the bank
okay I'm gonna member touch this one
myself okay we discover that hopefully
you don't okay ready yeah putting your
hands oh my god hey
it's always asked of behind crabs
excellent start
hey hey you got it right good job ah it
smells yeah it smells like this is my
wife okay it's a nice item um I don't
really look like this slimy oh my god
why is it so wet
I don't know why it's wet isn't it
edible
yeah it should be I've eaten it before
business looks weird is it some kind of
meat no it's none of me
yes it uses a spice usually like it'll
you put it in things to spice it up they
put this giant eye I guess I shave
partner ha ha oh is it garlic
no but Reds right I don't know I don't
know what horseradish which I get to the
giant some petrified mummy dildo my
hands for you or not that's disgusting
the cutters watching is right outside oh
my god let me get paper towels because
you might get oh my god that's kind of
fun okay some people like to eat this
people don't I don't like to eat at the
corner though so okay it's in a package
I want to put your hands trust me yes
okay
this is made for eating a plummet both
chunky and smoother like this tada this
one again to my god okay it sounds like
sausage I think so yeah
what it's not good to get that this is
just called how can we have braised hold
phallic things challenge okay one more
right yes well and it was nice and from
okay tada everyone home here's my last
item
um this one's not food Wow gross okay
it's on your head what I want -
yesterday I had a beet color in rest of
us were to get this we'll see if we can
beat that over his channel and the stuff
that he's gonna touch now I wish that I
have picked different things it's a
great toy torture but thank you for
watching and thank you for making me do
that Ricky you're welcome yeah
girlfriend News Channel and watch Ricky
touch some stuff down see if he can beat
me
hey guys I forgot to mention that memory
and I will be in Boston on March 15th
and we're doing a live show which are
very very excited about and we're
announcing it today that tickets go on
sale and it's a big big theater so we
hope that we can fill it with all of you
guys so please all of the information is
down in the just look down when in doubt
look down with strangers and with
information we're really excited it's
gonna be a live comedy show and it's
just a one-off show that we're doing and
it's gonna be around Saint Patrick's Day
and I hope you guys can come if you live
in and around the Boston area that's it
go buy tickets please kepta koat.com